salut je m'appelle marianne des hôtels
marsal je suis une ex biochimiste s'est
reconverti au journalisme scientifique
aujourd'hui je vous parlais de mes 1000
milliards d'amis c'est un livre que j'ai
écrit à propos du microbiome le
microbiome c'est un écosystème bactérien
qui vit sur nous mais surtout en nous
dans notre intestin
en fait c'est l'ancien flore intestinale
qu'on aurait découvert et on s'est rendu
compte que nos bactéries intestinales
était beaucoup plus importante au sein
notre santé qu'est ce qu'on croyait
avant elles vont éduquer notre système
immunitaire
un vent joue un rôle dans le contrôle de
nos émotions notre appétit elles sont
impliqués aussi dans des conditions
comme l'obésité le diabète et digèrent
une partie de notre nourriture
en retour elle nous offre des vitamines
et des molécules des composés qui
peuvent interagir avec notre système
immunitaire pour calmer une inflammation
par exemple alors comme le microbiome
est étroitement liée à l'alimentation
j'ai marié donne mes passions la
vulgarisation scientifique et la cuisine
dans mon livre alors j'espère que vous
prendrez autant de plaisir que j'en ai à
chouchouter votre micro billon